when training a neural network one of
the techniques to speed up your training
is if you normalize your inputs let's
see what that means let's see the
training sets with two input features so
the input features X are two-dimensional
and here's a scatterplot of your
training set normalizing your inputs
corresponds to two steps the first is to
subtract out or to zero out the mean so
you set mu equals 1 over m sum over I of
X I so this is a vector and then X gets
set as X minus mu for every training
example so this means you just move the
training set until it has zero mean and
then the second step is to normalize the
variances so notice here that the
feature x1 has a much larger variance
than the feature x2 here so what we do
is set Sigma equals 1 over m sum of X I
star saw two I guess this is element
wise squaring and so now Sigma squared
is a vector with the variances of each
of the features and notice we've already
subtracted out the means so X I squared
element Y squared is just the variances
and you take you an example and divide
it by you know this vector Sigma squared
and so in pictures you end up with this
where now the variance of x1 and x2 are
both equal to 1 oh into one tip if you
use this to scale your training data
then use the same mu and Sigma squared
to normalize your test set right in
particular you don't want to normalize
the training set and the test set
differently whatever this value is and
whatever this value is use them in you
know these two formulas so that you
scare your test set in exactly the same
way rather than estimating mu and Sigma
squared separately on your training set
and test
because you want your data both training
and test examples to go through the same
transformation defined by the same Mew
and Sigma squared calculated on your
training data so why do we do this why
do we want to normalize the input
features recall that the cost function
is defined as written on top right it
turns out that if you use unnormalized
input features is more likely that your
cost function will look like this at a
very squished out bow very elongated
cost function where you know the minimum
you're trying to find this maybe over
there but if you're beakers are on very
different scales say the feature x1
ranges from 1 to 1000 and the feature x2
ranges from 0 to 1 then it turns out
that ratio or the range of values for
the parameters w1 and w2 will end up
taking on very different values and so
maybe these axes should be w1 and w2
probe intuition I'll plot W and B be a
cost function can be a very elongated
bow like that so if you plot the
contours of this function you can have a
very elongated function like that
whereas if you normalize the features
then your cost function well on average
look more symmetric and if you are
running bathe in the scent on the cost
function like the one on the left then
you might have to use a very small
learning rate because over here
you know the grading descent might need
a lot of steps to oscillate back and
forth right before it finally finds its
way to the minimum whereas if you have a
more spherical contours than wherever
you start breathing descents can pretty
much go straight to the minimum you can
take much larger steps but gradient
descent need rather than needing to
oscillate around like the picture on the
left of course in practice W is a high
dimensional vector and so trying to plot
this in 2d doesn't convey all the
intuitions correctly but the rough
intuition that your cost function will
be you know more round and easier to
optimize
your features are all on similar skills
not all not from 1 to 1000 0 to 1 but
mostly from your minus 1 to 1 or with
about similar variants as each other
that just makes your cost function J
easier and faster to optimize in
practice if one feature say x1 ranges
from 0 to 1 and x2 ranges from minus 1
to 1 and x3 ranges from 1 to 2 you know
these are fairly similar ranges so this
will work just fine is when there are
dramatically different ranges like ones
from one to a thousand and another from
zero to one that that really hurts the
optimization algorithm but by just
setting all of them to zero mean and say
variance 1 like we did in the last slide
that just guarantees that all your
features are similar scale and will
usually help your learning Avrum run
faster so if your input features came
from very different scales maybe some
features are from 0 to 1 some from 1 to
1000 then it's important to normalize
your features if your features came in
on similar skills in this step is less
important although performing this type
of normalization pretty much never does
any harm so often you know do it anyway
if I'm not sure whether or not they were
help with speeding up training for your
algorithm so that's it for normalizing
your input features next let's keep
talking about ways to speed up the
training of your new network